well i thought we'd talk about something
um which
you know i've been looking into anyway
because um a part of my cryptography
teaching but it's the linear feedback
shift register
now what i really like about them is
it's unbelievably simple in structure
and yet it can produce incredibly
complicated seemingly output which i
think is really really cool they're used
a lot so they're used in things like
random number generators they are used
to an extent for cryptography as well as
elements of stream ciphers they're also
really easy to code right and we'll have
a look at one later
an lfsr or a linear feedback shift
register is just a set of bits and we're
going to have some rules about what we
do to move those bits around right so
let's start with one that's let's say of
length four okay so i'm going to draw my
little shift register here right and i'm
gonna kind of initialize these at random
so i know one zero zero one
all right so this is four bits each one
can be a zero or a one
and um
this outputs the bit at the end so this
is going to be outputting one and this
is called the state so let's see what do
we do with this to make it more
interesting because at the moment it
doesn't do anything well what we're
going to do every time we iterate we're
going to replace the state with a new
one and we're going to begin by shifting
everything to the right so
1 0 0 1 shifted 1 to the right becomes 1
0 0 the one disappears
and then we have to have something to go
in here if you just did this in
programming it would become a zero but
this is a linear feedback shift register
so what we're going to do is feedback
some linear combination of these which
we call taps right so i'm going to say
let's say take this one
and this one we're going to xor them
together do you remember about xor right
and then they're going to come in here
so xor is one or the other but not both
right so xor of zero and one
is one so that's going to be a one right
and then this outputs a zero right and
then we're going to iterate this
over again right and so you can see that
this has changed and it's going to
change again it's going to change again
and let's see how it goes so the next
state we're going to shift 1 to the
right so 1
uh 1 0 and then 0x or 0 is 0. we're
going to go again so zero one one
xord is one right so far so good so i'll
work my way through these give me a
minute because there's actually quite a
few of them
one zero one and that's zero
one one and that's a one oh all ones
that's exciting most exciting bit so far
for me right let's keep going one one
one and that's a zero we're getting
there naught one
one
i mean if i made a mistake it we won't
know until the end um and that's a zero
and then a zero and this is zero zero
one and that's a one right and we're
finally
thank goodness for that back at the
beginning right which was our initial
state now this is going to output a 0 a
1 1 0 1 0 1 1 1 1 0 0 0 1 so this is the
actual output of our little random
number generator
so what's interesting about what i've
just done right because it's just a load
of zeros and ones well the cool thing
about this is it took quite a long time
to repeat itself and in fact it actually
took the maximum amount of time possible
if you've got four bits
then there are two to the four possible
zeros and one combinations you could
have but all zeros doesn't appear
because you can you can imagine that if
you had all zeroes in here it would
always stay as all zeros because zero x
or zero is zero you'd never get anything
interesting so zero never appears all
zeroes but this is a period of 15 i
think let's check one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven
twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen oh
thank goodness for that um so it's a
period of fifteen
and that's the maximum of
that that's the maximum period for this
little shift register here right so
actually if you have a shift register
which is n bits then the actual period
the maximum period you could have
is two to the n minus one right which is
two to the n all the different
combinations of notes and ones minus one
which is the zeros which you wouldn't
have
now
you might what what i really what i
think is cool about this right is this
is an unbelievably simple structure
there's nothing to this there's a shift
to the right and a little xor and we've
got all the possible combinations of
notes and ones and this holds
essentially for any length of bit of
shift register so if i had a 100 bit
shift register
and i had these taps set up correctly i
could go through every possible
combination of notes and ones of length
100 before i cycled around again does
tap stun for something or is it no taps
is just sometimes the word people use
for just tapping off these and coming in
here right it's got nothing to do with
plumbing
to my knowledge could we make this more
complicated right so let's suppose we
had an internal state that started with
one zero zero one again let's say
we're going to
we're going to come off three taps
instead and come back round to the
beginning right now it looks to me like
that's better than that because there's
more interesting xor going on it seems
to be more powerful so let's whiz
through this one we're going to shift
towards shift to the right 100 and then
one x or zero x or one
is
zero right so we're going to put that in
here and then we're going to shift right
again so
01 0
and
0 0 0 0. that's so far so good and then
the next one is 001 and
0x or 1 x or 0
is one right and we've already found
ourselves back at the beginning right
now this is a deterministic random
number generator in a sense that if
you're in some state and you've got your
rule you're always going to produce the
exact same state that you had before
right it seems obvious so this repeats
itself after what one two three has a
period of three
so choosing these taps is quite
important right now mathematically we
won't dwell on some maths but there are
mathematical ways to choose these taps
in such a way that you can guarantee it
will produce the maximum period for some
lfsr of some length right and that way
you can take a lot of the unknowns out
of this you don't have to plow through
two to the 128 different combinations of
bits before you realize oh good it has
got a long cycle right
um
so let's have a go at coding this up
it's super straightforward these these
um they're not hugely efficient in
software because you have to spend a lot
of time looping and shifting things
around doing a lot of unnecessary xors
in hardware you can imagine that you
could literally just have some gates
here and just do this and each of these
could be a flip-flop and maybe that's a
good project for steve to build at some
point right the cool thing about lfsrs
is
they are unbelievably easy to program
right because
all you do is a bit of bit shifting and
you basically done it a couple of exors
um python allows you to do this
python is a slightly odd language in a
way to do bit shifting of things in
because it has these arbitrary length
integers but it works so let's have a go
let's do our four bit a little little
shift register let's not get too carried
away right so state equals a binary
value of 101. let's do 20 iterations to
begin with so for i in range 20 that's
so so far so good and then each time we
loop we want to output a value
which is you know the current last bit
and then we want to
um
anyone do shifting in fact let's not
output a bit let's just output the whole
state because then we can see it and we
can see the period and things like this
i hate string formatting right so let's
do a print
and then we're going to print our state
in binary format which in um
we can use using a string format so it's
going to be something like
0 4b
dot format state right let's see if that
works so that should print out our state
20 times but it's not actually updating
anything because i haven't coded that so
let's see
yes it worked
one zero zero ones it's the least
interesting program ever let's keep
going
all right so now we need to actually
update so what we'll do is we'll do a
shift but we'll also we need to
calculate the new bit so let's say new
bit is equal to
and then remember
what we wanted to do was calculate some
xor of bits one and bit zero we're
coming from the right hand side all
right so
let's do an xor of the state
xor is the hat operator in python and in
many languages and we're going to also
xor it with state shifted one
to the right
right so what's that doing well let's
get my piece of paper if our state was
one zero zero one
and we're xoring that with our state
shifted one to the right then we're
xoring that with o one zero zero which
means that the output is going to be one
one o one but it's the last bit is the
one we want so now we're going to just
let's put my pen down before i draw all
over my brand new laptop and it's
permanent as well and then we're going
to and that with one and just take the
last bit right so that's our new bit
now obviously all we need to do now is
shift our state to the right and put our
bit at the front so we're going to say
state is equal to
state
shifted
shifted one to the right
okay and then we're going to all that
which will essentially
set
our bit on the left-hand side with our
new bit and we're going to shift that
into the right position so that's going
to be it's in the zero position one two
three three three to the left
just like that all right and i think
that's done that's it so let's just put
that out and see what happens
uh and that's exactly right so what it
does it starts with one zero zero one
one one zero zero and it goes on and you
can see down here somewhere 15
um
iterations on we get one zero zero one
right now in in actual fact what you
wouldn't do is print out the state
because the state doesn't change much
between iterations it just moves one to
the right only the left bit changes if
you're actually using an lfsr for let's
say a random number generator you
wouldn't output the whole state because
all the status is shifted to the right
so it would look very similar each time
so what we instead do is just output the
last value so instead of printing out
the whole state we'll just output the
last bit so all we need to do is remove
this and we'll just say we want to add
print out state
and one now in python it's very
difficult to avoid putting a character
turn on the end so i'll just put in
end equals nothing right like that and
let's try that
um
and you can see it just prints out now a
little binary stream which we could
theoretically use as a random number
generator or we could use it as a i mean
you'd be unwise to use it as a stream
cipher but it could be a component of a
stream cipher let's make a little bit of
a bigger one because that's much more
interesting right i'm going to now make
128 bit cipher instead so first of all
instead of our state being just one zero
zero one which is not very interesting
let's make our state one
shifted 127 to the left or
one right and so that's going to be one
zero zero zero one where it's 128 bits
long right it's a much bigger
lfsr and we don't want to um only output
20 bits so let's just do wild true and
just break the whole you know just go on
forever
and we're still going to print out the
state and we're just going to change our
taps slightly so i happen to know a set
of taps there's a few of different
combinations obviously um for this
particular lfsr are zero one two and
seven if you x or those together then
you're gonna get that whole maximum
period of two to the n minus one so
let's put that in there you go so what
i've done is i've got the state which is
you know shifted no times then shifted
one time shifted two times and shifted
seven times and one to get only the last
bit and then we're going to do the same
thing as before state is state shifted
one to the right and then we're going to
shift our new bit 127 positions to the
left and put it right in on the end
right now that should work i mean let's
not verify it my coding live but if we
if we run it
it's just going to start printing out an
awesome ones now this
lfsr has a period of two to 128 minus
one let's say for the sake of argument
two to 128. this laptop given that it
has to output to the screen is doing
probably around a million bits per
second we will probably be waiting for
10 20 times the lifetime of the universe
before this repeats itself so i don't
know how much
sd card memory you've got on your camera
what's the actual use for the system so
these are used all the time for random
number generators advanced versions of
these are used for some of the most
popular random number generators right
the statistical randomness of these
streams is really really good and what i
mean by that is this will appear as
random
as just flipping a coin right so if you
want to just generate coin flips this is
a great way to do it this is not
cryptographically secure because if you
have a large portion of the stream you
can just essentially solve a bunch of
linear equations and recompute the lfsr
generated it and then generate the next
sets so
it's essentially you can reverse
engineer based on some output what the
next bits will be which is exactly what
you don't want if you've got a stream
cipher but if you join some of these
things together so let's say you have
two stream ciphers that are xored
together and maybe they don't always
tick over and shift at the same time and
things like this if you've got some
non-linear combination of stream size of
lfsrs then you actually can have
something that's pretty pretty robust
and this has been used in the past for
mobile phone encryption
and um you know the trivium cipher is
based on this so they do see a lot of
use and they're unbelievably quick in
hardware which of course is really
really useful for low power devices like
smart cards and stuff like that
do not try this at home absolutely only
try this at home oh yeah that's a very
good try this at home but not anywhere
else at all in some sense remember when
we talked about 3d images you could view
rgb as in some sense 3d so the first
plane is our r g and b or vice versa